it's very scary I'm moving over the
weekend so it's just yes yes so it's
been a wonderful I had a wonderful time
being here I look forward to being
around Saint Louis as much as possible
and I've always watched you this was a
pleasure working with you well thank you
Alejandro enough oh yeah get out of here
get out of here we're jaded with him but
we're gonna jump over to Madrid as
Anastasia caught up with our tournament
winner and now Challenger nepo foreign
today but at some point it looked a
little bit scary what about you
uh well I have some wonderful
analyst in my team here who came up with
this A5 rookie 6 idea like very very
nice and I think I mean the only
drawback if you didn't repeat this like
uh
the morning to play the game yeah uh you
could find yourself in trouble but uh
okay I just
I I could barely remember what's like uh
what are my most but I thought like okay
five rookie six and then okay what
happens happens yeah uh but somehow I
think what he did it is quite natural
and it's it's somehow leads to some
you know a bunch of forced drills but uh
uh I only like I can't help but I want
I won't mix up everything
yes so at the end of the day plus five I
mean now it's time finally to enjoy now
it's time we're indeed now it's time to
enjoy so what are the plans for the
evening uh I won't tell you
okay but we will probably see something
from social media and actually yeah yeah
I realize you don't have time to rest
and Grant Your Story will start very
very soon so are you going to play and
what are your plans you are going to
meet mamus also
I have no idea if he's playing there
yeah uh okay then it's good uh well
hopefully as far as I remember it's not
starting tomorrow yes I'll have
I don't know about 10 days break and uh
yeah like you know exhale a little bit
and uh we'll see but uh yeah I'm looking
forward to finally you know some some
Years of Awesome huge pressure
what what are you going to do now that
you will are you going to go back to
Russia or you will stay here for some
time no I think I already like had quite
a long journey like for the last couple
of months yeah so a lot of just a lot of
work a lot of Journey so yeah I guess
it's time to go home and uh yeah have
some rest thank you very much thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you